i want to say something in all the
sincerity which is i remember
i it was very important to me to get
certain people to come here as we
wrap up this uh phase of the show and i
i really wanted you here very glad that
you could be here and i'll tell you why
uh you guys may not know this but jb was
a writer on saturday live
yes and the first time i met you we uh
cast you in something
uh and you were a writer you weren't
known at all you weren't famous
you did this sketch for us you were
hilarious the minute you came out people
laughed
then we started saying every time let's
get jb let's get
we kept pulling you downstairs from
starting out live you would do stuff for
us
you were always money in the bank
hilarious
hilarious and then you went off and your
career has completely blown up and
you're one of the funniest people i know
and i
couldn't be happier for you and you're
such a nice person and it felt
this is nice full circle like let's just
get together and
uh you know these last couple of days
and and see jb
smooth because you're the real deal
you're a fantastic guy conan let me tell
you something man
and you know i say this with the utmost
of love and respect for you man
you have been absolutely an amazing
piece
of my comedy journey and it's very
important that people understand that
this dude right here he works hard man
this
dude this dude
when you find genuine people in this
business man you you
you take it man and you take it anytime
this man needs me
i'm looking forward to your next
adventure man i can't wait to see where
you're land
and i i told you know what i was
thinking about you should you should
have had a uh
where you're going at like a network or
like people do those
gender reveals
does what ginger a gender gender reveal
how gender right pink or or
blue and and they pop the [ __ ] bubble
and it'd be a
it's a girl you know we're having a girl
whatever yeah you should have a reveal
it should be like a bam and it's it's a
cooking show no yeah
yeah whatever oh corning that's perfect
for you it's no i i can't cook at all i
would be
i hate i would hate that that would be a
terrible thing
well is it up to me do i get to decide
or is it revealed to me at the same time
you're a morning sports caster [ __ ]
that's bad
i love it no that's bad i don't know
like a grab bag full of [ __ ] like
you know i shouldn't know that would be
great a reality show where i don't
know what show i'm going to do next and
it's
random and it's revealed to me it's
chosen by a medical test
yeah some
kind of medical test yes yes yes yes i
love it
so you do fix things i do fix things
here's what i don't want to happen i
don't want your punk ass
to get up here your last show right
and and [ __ ] tears start welling up
in your ass okay
and and i know i know they're coming up
because your tears
fill your body up from the waist up
what are you talking about you're
telling me you do not want any cheers on
the final night
i'm telling you it's like when you hold
the fart in you didn't have [ __ ]
you hope when you hold a farting you
just farted inside your own [ __ ] body
so right now you you are crying
inside your own body
so no crying no crying no all right you
leave this
[ __ ] defiant defiant defiant to the end
[ __ ] you leave you make sure he does
this
fire okay leave him defiant
you you you have done so much amazing so
many amazing damn shows man
i want you to be content in what the
[ __ ] you have accomplished
and i want you to leave this
[ __ ]
to buy it i want you to take
like you you have a car a vehicle it's
not a real car
it's your vehicle you've been driving
this vehicle for a long ass time
it's gotten you that same [ __ ]
vehicle made your ass run from [ __ ]
new york all the way to l.a remember
that time
yeah and remember that yeah
a stupid-ass suit on him dumb shoes yeah
in the desert in a [ __ ] desert he ran
through all that [ __ ]
what's that that's that forest glasses i
know i know
okay so so i will leave defiant
and confident you take this metaphor and
you run with this [ __ ]
you take one [ __ ] foot right
you swear on them why put the foot down
swear
so much i gotta get this i got to get
this through to you put your foot down
put your foot down yeah okay
now you're driving the car yeah
okay yeah take one foot and put that one
foot on the brake
right yep get the other foot and put it
on the gas yeah
this is how my dad drives yeah push down
push down on that brake yeah and push
down on that gas
oh whoa burning rubber you're damn right
yeah
i want you to leave here defiantly
like i did what i came to do and i'm
out this [ __ ]
all right now when you hold your foot on
that gas
yeah yeah yeah yeah you do this do this
do it i'm gonna do it first
you gotta you gotta when you leave you
gotta do this all right go i'm out this
[ __ ] do it
i'm out this [ __ ]
davey smalls